las llamas han empezado a dejar espacio
al humo en matanzas después de cinco
días de combatir el fuego en las
instalaciones de combustibles más
importantes de la isla los bomberos
entraron por primera vez en el área y
rociaron con espuma y agua a restos aún
humeantes aunque la situación mejoró las
llamas siguen siendo preocupantes
ahora vamos a comenzar a trabajar unidos
por compañeros de mexico y de venezuela
en los tres sectores de bomba le vamos a
incorporar ya a penetrar
a tratar de ir enfriando y todavía sin
pronóstico todavía el incendio es un
gran incendio el incendio inició el
viernes luego del impacto de un rayo
sobre uno de los ocho tanques de
combustible para este lunes cuatro de
ellos ya habían colapsado ante la
conflagración y las altas temperaturas
el objetivo ahora es proteger la batería
de los otros depósitos en un momento en
que cuba ya está luchando contra los
cortes de electricidad
los habitantes de matanza se preparan
para lo peor los daños son base
significativo y considerable porque el
combustible que genera la corriente del
país nuevamente a la hilera
yo pienso que traigas un baño grande
pensamos que la situación empeore porque
es petróleo de todos los casos se ha
perdido o se ha dañado reservas que
habían ahí de petróleo y entonces todo
va a ser muy muy difícil ahora según las
autoridades un bombero murió y 14
desaparecieron en el incendio más de 100
personas resultaron heridas y 22 siguen
hospitalizados